we're learning more about Geoffrey
Epstein's alleged crimes on his own
Caribbean island from people who live
nearby the late fee a financier is
accused of trafficking underage girls to
the private island near st. Thomas
sexually assaulting them and keeping
them there against their will mola legi
has been gathering these witness
accounts
well good morning you know some locals
we've spoken to here in st. Thomas say
that Jeffrey Epstein's alleged crimes on
his private island were somewhat of an
open secret some even refer to it as
pedophile Island one alleged victim we
spoke to wants to know why he wasn't
charged sooner people we spoke to here
tell us Jeffrey Epstein rarely left his
private island but word about his
alleged crimes on little st. James did
along with rumors about the 13 months
sentence Epstein received over a decade
ago for procuring an underage girl in
Florida for sex charter captain Jim
query what was the talk about little st.
James Island
yeah the talk was just that he had
gotten some crazy sweetheart deal we
were always just told it was a super
short sentence and maybe some time of
house arrest I never knew that was true
on the island but that there was
basically little to no penalty to get to
little say James Epstein first flew into
nearby st. Thomas where he also had
steaks and several businesses including
Hyperion Air according to the lawsuit
Hyperion Ayer owns the two helicopters
Epstein allegedly used to transport
young women and underage girls between
st. Thomas and little st. James US
Virgin Islands Attorney General Denise
George says the web of companies made it
difficult to monitor the convicted sex
offender was this done to conceal his
identity we believe it is and we alleged
that it was Epstein's other alleged
business ventures included a company
called Southern trust he also allegedly
had ties to the American yacht harbor
neither company is named as a defendant
in the lawsuit a harbor employee told us
this boat with the letters LS J is used
to ferry workers and supplies to and
from little st. James
according to local media outlets Epstein
also donated money to local government
officials in the US Virgin Islands and
donated dozens of
computers to be given away at schools
was he known on the island as being
someone who was philanthropic or donated
to charitable causes or an upstanding
member of the community in any other
capacity I certainly I can't comment
fully on that but definitely I do not
think he was regarded as an upstanding
member of the community was very it was
public knowledge that he was a
registered sex offender George who took
office just months before Epstein's
death by suicide last year is now suing
Epstein's estate alleging he continued
his sex trafficking operation here until
at least 2018 for one alleged victim we
spoke to on the condition of anonymity
the lawsuit is a bit late in the game to
me it's sort of last minute and there's
victims from I think the 80s 90s I think
that I think a lot of people knew who
what he was up to it I don't know why
nothing was done before do you think a
blind eye was turned to mr. Epstein's
crimes I cannot comment on that but what
I do know is that once we got here this
new administration that we will not turn
a blind eye we will enforce it
well according to local government
officials here Jeffrey Epstein made the
US Virgin Islands his permanent
residency in 2010 Gail thank you very
much mullah lankey reporting the
questions still continue even after his
death yes still so just there's so much
we don't know about what went on there